[Laughter]
did that happen
i don't think so oh [ __ ] if you say it
did it happen how's that
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today we're talking to
my dad tj patrick and i just thought it
would be really interesting
to sit down and kind of grill my dad i i
i don't know does anyone really sit down
and grill your grill your dad about like
deep subjects and really dive into the
psyche
and you know ask questions think about
questions that you've never asked before
because you just take them for granted
because it's your dad well i did so
um we talked about all kinds of things
and talked about childhood
he told me the true story of how we
started racing which is different than
mine and i'm super bummed about it but
hey
truth is truth so um we had fun
and it was nice to hear stories that
even i've never heard
so please enjoy dad welcome to the
pretty intense podcast
thank you thank you for inviting me were
you surprised that i asked you
yeah a little bit why well you can't
know everything about me already so it's
like
what more can you need to learn oh we'll
get there
oh we'll get there dad don't you worry
about that you know i'm a crazy kooky
hippie i'm gonna go deep on you
well don't ask questions you're not
going to want to hear the answer to then
well we're going to we're going to we're
going to we're going to get to those
emotions that are in there
that there's a lot of them that sit on
the top
right like you and i both we both cry
really easily
i feel like are you trying to be barbara
walters or what
yes you're gonna get the barber moment
with brown hair
um but you know i think that's you know
as a daughter and a father like you
don't really talk about like well how
does it make you feel
but we're gonna do that today a little
bit all right
let's see how it goes um
so what was i uh what was i like as a as
a kid was i
was i uh one of those ones that made you
not want to have another one
i mean obviously i have a sister but i
don't think so
as you know i i wasn't around as much as
mom
i was around sunday mornings maybe
you know because i worked all the time
so i didn't get to see every day
um i got to know you more after we
started racing rather than before well
that was obviously why we did it
exactly which we're going to go over
that story because i want to make sure
it was right because i've been asked a
million times
well you know how'd you start racing and
of course i tell the pontoon story
pontoon boat story and so you're gonna
tell it so see what the difference is
um but okay well that makes me think of
another question is like did you really
i mean if you weren't even there
did you were you like surprised to have
kids so young or was that the plan
no that was the plan all along and have
kids young i think the plan was
yeah but we weren't gonna start like
business just married
yeah we were just married but i went to
work for somebody and
then when you guys were probably three
or four
i just started to start a business from
scratch yeah
i know so that wasn't planned yeah we
just you know it's one of those things
where
i think i can do it better so that's
what we did and to do it better you had
i had to spend a lot of time there
yeah well i know that business started
in our garage
yeah i remember yes because my bicycle
had nowhere to be
um but so you okay you and mom married
in 1980
you just had your 39th wedding
anniversary
you were you guys were born in 58 and 59
so you guys got married you were
you were like uh 21 22 21 22 yeah and so
you thought
let's have kids right away yes i mean
i'm 37 so i'm trying to wrap my noggin
around this
well that's what people did you had kids
why do you think they did it
why is that is it like because you
really really wanted to or is that just
the norm
yeah was that just the no no it's
because we wanted to yeah what else she
into i mean
well i don't know there's all kinds of
stuff you could do
i mean a lot of people choose to have
them later we chose them earlier
but not back then back then people had
kids younger
yeah well i was i mean i feel like if
you won't gonna have kids like
earlier or later right you know
play early or play late right because
you guys are 60 now
ish and you guys are still i mean you
guys just went
on a trip to singapore and you've been
to greece and you went to italy and
you're now taking the time to do the big
trips which i'm doing right now right
um so i kind of am for that theory of
having
really young mm-hmm or or a little old
because you're broke then anyway
so why does that logical work well
you got nothing else to raise kids i
mean so if you have
kids when you're later and you seem to
have a little bit more money you can't
travel because you got kids
you know so i don't know i
i think i want to be if i i mean i i
felt like i was a kid with you guys i
mean we did
things like kids did yeah right yeah i
wouldn't want to be a father being
right now and having a eight or ten year
old kid
little bastards wear you out
i know you and mom well mostly mom
watches
brooke my sisters little kids who are
three and five
yeah um and you know two days in a row
is a lot that's exhausting yeah
yeah so i wouldn't want to do it when
i'm older yeah but
i see i think i look at like 21 and i'm
like oh my gosh you were a kid
i think of all the dumb things that i
did at 21 or the mistakes that i made or
the life
changes that have happened since i've
been 21 i mean
well you're still gonna do dumb stuff
even when you get old do you yeah you
just have
do you just have to wake up in the
morning yep you just it's not so dumb
you just do it
you just don't care anymore just don't
care anyone is that it that's it
a whole lot of who gives a [ __ ] did you
give a [ __ ] when you were 21
i'm not a no yeah i did i did
you know you didn't want to screw up but
you you do it just out of doing things i
mean that's what life's all about ain't
it
you learn from mistakes so do you feel
like you missed out on stuff then having
kids and getting married so young
no not a bit no
i wouldn't change anything did your
parents have you and randy when you guys
were really young
or when they were really young yep same
like same age
my mom was born in 42 and she had me in
59
17. oh god yeah you guys were yeah you
guys were really mature then
and married right she probably wasn't
married or was she at 17. yeah
to my dad yeah is that legal
back then in the 50s it must have been
oh my gosh all right um so all right you
didn't feel like you missed out on
anything you kind of still got to be a
kid
okay we'll tell the pond's tomb boat
story so everybody asks me they're like
how did you start out in racing and i
always tell them
my version of it which it's better if
you tell the version and i'll tell you
if it was any different from what i say
but it's a kind of a fun serendipitous
story
i'm i'm trying to recall it all exactly
it'll be it'll be close basically i was
um
i was helping buddy mine race cars
because i had race cars
dirt midgets and uh i couldn't afford it
anymore so i helped a good friend of
mine
joe corrigan and one week he got really
busted up and
he probably shouldn't race again he got
all tore up
so was the one where his eyes were black
eyes were blown like yeah he last raised
faceless black and blue yeah lassrey is
kidney
and all kinds of stuff pancreas didn't
work
so i said joe why don't we just buy a
pontoon boat rather than going racing
every weekend
you know i'm thinking we'll just cruise
around and drink beer on a boat that's a
good idea
it's a lot of fun so we looked at boats
and it didn't happen
and um so it's like to stay busy in the
weekends what i didn't we
decided hey let's try go-karts because
uh the one babysitter was racing
theresa yeah theresa mayer milan yeah
and brooke went to school brooke was in
the same grade as theresa's
sister sister younger sister can't
remember her name but
yeah and they lived in the neighborhood
right okay
so they they race go curse and i asked
and brooke says
you know because she was you know she
slept with the joe corrigan shirt and
all that and
she goes i want a race so we said all
right let's try go-karts i'll take one
day off a week and sundays and we'll go
racing go-karts who is the braver of the
two of us
growing up brooke or me
duh a good question um i don't know i
don't
i don't know if there's a brave
difference really you were both very
repetitive you wear the same clothes the
same it's your
same dress you wear a dress every day
mm-hmm i'm girly that's what i tell
people about me they're like you were
dressed
what do you think would surprise me
about you that i don't know and i'm like
that i'm kind of girly
yeah burke was probably more the tomboy
okay then cause i don't feel very brave
but yet brooke wanted a race and i just
didn't want to get left out
that's how i remember it yeah you said
you'd try it
i said i'd try it until you try it yeah
so we know you know
so we bought two go-karts and i tried
that's a similar story i mean my story
was that you wanted to
so my story was that you wanted to spend
more time with brooke and i because you
worked so you were going to get a
pontoon boat but instead
um it was a little less about joel
corrigan a little bit more
broken high in the love but you know
it's okay it's probably part of the
story yeah
um and and then you you know instead of
so the pontoon boat started we didn't
buy pontoon but why did we buy go-kart
stat
so i could do it by we i so you take one
day off we can spend with your kids no
why we didn't buy a pontoon boat no we
didn't why
i didn't know enough about them or this
is a critical part of the story
i don't think i looked that hard to be
honest i thought it was an idea
dad well here's the story let me tell
you how you need to tell it moving
forward because it's better
um that you called somebody about
pontoon boat
and they never called back okay
did that happen i don't think so oh [ __ ]
if you say it did it happen how's that
i can tell why you've been married for
almost 40 years yeah good job if i had a
white flag i'd be throwing it up in the
air like a [ __ ] flag too
so no you didn't ever call to buy one i
don't know i don't remember doing so
i may have i don't know i'm old did mom
mom she was the bookkeeper she wouldn't
have called on it
you're right mom's not very
confrontational she wouldn't have wanted
to make that phone call
so unless it was about getting paid she
calls about that yeah
being the accountant that she is so
that's an interesting story too you
scooped mom up from northern
northern minnesota she lived like
on the border of canada and minnesota
and she was going to be an accountant
and yeah she was going to school and
then you what's the word you did what
you
saved her i saved her yeah
because you got her out of northern i
told her that all the time i saved her
okay um how did you and mom meet
it was a blind date and she was blind
ah we got set up on our blind spot
that's your humor i got mom's
i don't know about that brook's so funny
i laugh so much
um okay so you met on a blind date
set up by the delightful sue decker
um who was and she didn't race though
yeah she raised
sue race mom used to work on sue's
snowmobile okay
and my middle name is sue because sue
set you guys up on the blind date
correct
yep you got that right and sue's still
around silly hell yeah
i see soon more than i ever used to
exactly and i tell everyone that story
and luckily that one's accurate
and how ironic there's no bigger packer
van in the world than sue dekker oh my
god
right when that happened i'm like geez
this could have been any other team
like we grew up on the border and you
were a cradle bears fan and i'm like
geez this is just candy this girl paints
her fingernails
green everything oh i know all of her
cars are green
i know i know well she probably bleeds
green
they're a fun team to watch anyway um
okay so we started racing go-karts
and you know like we were gone a ton
and you had your own business so how
what year do you remember what you we
started racing in 91 but you're the
business that you started
on your own was what year 87
87 it started in the garage 11 187.
you're a numbers guy i'm not a numbers
guy um
so an 87 started in the garage and then
when did you buy the
shop or when did you start renting space
in the shop to probably
work out of a real facility probably um
probably april may of 91 like the
year we started racing 92 i mean we
so right around the same time right so
not very far off not very far off
so you still so you so you were like
just getting out of like
broke broke broke land right well we
started
on hardly nothing it was it was a sink
or swim
one like money money reference i have
from
back in those days of like 1980 to you
know now
2019. a couple years ago i bought a
picnic table
at home depot and it was a hundred bucks
and i remember you said that you and mom
spent your last hundred dollars on a
picnic table
for the first house and so how about
that everybody let's get a hand to the
market for keeping picnic tables at a
hundred dollars
yeah right well they couldn't my grandpa
had to buy me a lawnmower because we
didn't have enough money left by alarm
work at the grass
yeah that and so if you don't have
enough money for a lawn mower that means
you ain't got enough money for a blown
man
nope or a woman no lawn person what can
we even say these days that's kind of
enjoyable doing it anyway
yeah i mowed the grass once it was fine
i did it for a workout though
i think i ran it i literally ran the
push mower just so that i could get a
workout yeah i'd probably look like [ __ ]
probably the lines weren't straight no
i'm worried straight now um
okay so all right so well we you know we
race a lot right and
how did you do how did you even have
enough money to buy go-karts
you worked a ton that's what i remember
i remember you worked a lot
and so maybe i feel like i feel like i
got my
hard work determination perseverance
gene from you
to like think big and just
believe that anything's possible and
everything's possible
and you know but it doesn't mean that
there isn't hard work in there
right like it it just makes the hard
work not feel so big of a deal right it
makes it not feel so hard and so
exhausting because you have a goal
and then doing the work work air quotes
is just
part of getting to the to the to the end
product which was
you know if you're running a glass
business like you were it probably
wasn't
because you loved being outside you
probably like just enjoyed
you know semi enjoyed the job but it was
you want to make money that's what i
knew and it's what you knew
my parents had a glass company so that's
why i started it because i i knew a
little bit about it
more than most people and yeah we i mean
we worked a lot of hours
yeah it was you know a couple employees
is all and
yeah you know i had no fabricator i had
to build and fab and bid and
measure and yeah there were five six
seven years where it was
17 15 17 18 hours a day every day
i remember being a kid up in the uh the
the the law
office the office office so it was a big
big
square just it was above the uh we had
it we had a 3 000 square foot building
and the office area might have been 800
square feet and above the offices
that's ambitious it was smaller than
that but it was above that because i
saw a picture recently and brooke and i
were both like we remember it being
giant that thing was a peephole like
that was just like it was like a toilet
bathroom how crazy was that there was no
railing no nothing oh no
so anyway it's you know 12 feet up in
the air is just the top of it because
it's a giant
warehouse and so brooke and i would go
up there and we'd call it our office
because below it was your office
and we that was the birth of me wanting
to be a secretary when i when i grew up
because we got like
calendars and we had a phone papers
paper we'd pretend like we were playing
secretary and i thought it was the
coolest thing ever
for hours yeah every night yeah and we'd
have sleeping bags up there
like two in the morning or something
whatever it took whatever it took
um and so who taught you like
who taught you to give a [ __ ] like that
like who taught you to either work hard
or care enough to to work till 2 a.m
like people just don't do that
i don't do that i don't work till two i
think that it boils down to
it's pretty simple it's just fear of
failure i mean yeah it could
could have been easy to go home early
and oh [ __ ] it didn't work out no i
wasn't gonna let it fail well who taught
you that though i don't know if anybody
taught me that
you know i mean i believe in the whole
nature nurture thing but
on some level you had to have seen
someone
not really not that i know
total self-starter yeah i just
even when i raced snowmobiles or did
whatever it was like
you work as hard as you had to you did
what it takes
that's you know you get out of where you
put into it
you know it would have been easy to quit
everything halfway done and you get
half-assed results so would you have
just made less money if you wouldn't
have done more or would you have not
been able to keep the business up i
don't think we would have kept the
business open because
uh my i thrived on my business
with service because service has kind of
gone off the window i made sure i gave
everybody service i was going to be
there and
say they'd be there monday i'd be there
monday
in construction you're an angel then
because that doesn't happen
that's right so when they call you and
want a job done
they don't care if you're a little bit
higher if they know you're going to get
the job done mm-hmm
oh for sure so that that was how i did
my business
and to do that you just had to work more
yeah which means you end up getting more
work which means you made a little bit
more money and
yeah you know well people are usually if
they can
which you know if they're doing a big
business if they're doing a transaction
like that they
people will pay a premium to know
they're going to get to get what they
want
i just don't get it on time and to get
it done well you know i had people
i started a couple other business had
people work for me in other businesses
and they worked like eight nine hours a
day and i look at them going
dude you can't do that and run a
business it's a full day dad no it's not
no it's not well it's a full day for a
regular person if
well were they an investor were they
gonna were they did they own part of the
company or were they just getting paid
salary
were they salaried yeah well there's
your problem
you have to have equity right i mean i
think that that's how
that's how i operate in my businesses is
i try and yes i have employees yes but
um you know in the things moving forward
a lot of the stuff i've done with
structure is like
you know i'm in urine like i want you to
make
more money if i do because that is the
incentive like i want people around me
that want to
want to do the job so did you ever think
that like i mean oh yeah
it was it was that wasn't the issue it
was just
lack of motivation self motivation i
think you know
it was a 50 50 deal he was going to make
50 of the profit i put all the money in
oh yeah so more it did mean more money
than more yeah absolutely i mean he
wouldn't even
see that yeah yeah wouldn't work weekend
just like
man that's time when you make hay you
get ahead of the game yeah
yeah that's that's it write that down
everybody
that's i mean that's when you get ahead
of the game and make hey
when you're working when other people
don't um i agree
i mean you that's what i remember is you
working so much
so now you know i come back to this sort
of concept
or question but you know having
done all that right like you work a lot
you then we started racing
so on your make hey we're racing now so
not only are you
not making money but now you're spending
money
um and you're not you're not doing
anything else now i mean i know you and
you and mom are like home bodies it's
not like you're party animals and
i mean you know i know that when i was a
kid and i saw you drink a beer every now
and again at like a family function like
christmas or something i'm like
do you remember i was like dad you're
you're wrecking your
liver yeah you did that a lot you're
wrecking your liver
you're wrecking your liver i don't even
i don't even know what that meant
um but you and mom like you didn't go
out like you didn't drink you didn't you
know you didn't you weren't
i mean other than buying your pantera
and your harley because you had
two mid-life crisis um you know you guys
were pretty
like you know normal yeah well i mean
those aren't normal but you know you're
pretty you're not
like you're you're you're at home you're
kind of home bodies
so but did you feel like there was
things that you wish you could have done
like i for instance
i can never make it to a farmer's market
i could never make it to
concerts i could never i knew i would
pretty much never make it to anyone's
wedding because they were always on the
weekends like there was so much stuff
that
i mean when i was racing i didn't go to
prom i never went to prom i went to one
homecoming
because you know the idiot on the next
one didn't take me at all which you were
really pissed about
um but you know i i mean i didn't do a
lot of things now were they sacrifices
they sure didn't feel like it at the
time
but when i look back there was there was
a lot that i didn't do
that most people do experience um
so do you feel like man
do you feel like you're living some of
those days now or do you feel like i
wish i had a little bit more time when i
was younger to
be 30 no i'm happy where i'm at now
i'm in good health i'm 60 and i can
come and do as i want back then you
didn't think about it it was like work
or racing that's what we did
you know we go racing in the weekends i
come back and you know we drive all
night get home at four in the morning
i'd be to work at six getting my guys
off and
he just went off adrenaline for a long
time i remember one time though in like
91 i got really sick it was like
i think my body went shut down oh my god
my body just went you need a break and i
was sick for like two or three months
yeah you didn't work for most of it i
couldn't work i
couldn't even get couldn't move i was
really it scared me and i think
that's how people get when your body
just shuts down goes you need a break
and you work till you find that and then
you
can go back at it you recharge no people
don't they do not work till they find
that
wait how do you know where it's at then
nobody tries to find that
nobody tries to try and find it from the
party perspective they don't try and
find it from the work perspective
you just do i mean i think it can
manifest in people right i think that
you know you ignore your body long
enough
and things fall you know things can be
um let go long enough to be a problem or
i also think that you know you work long
enough and it creates stress
and while it's part of the job it could
have been strong stress
stress is a killer just so cliche here
um but i mean that's where you know you
create this ease in the body through
abnormalities of cell
formations and you create cancer like
you
uh you you or you create a disease a
disease in the body and so i do think
that you know
you can get shut down in a way but i
mean that's that was a unique sickness
for you
when you were on the what was that
called the chair with the lever
no remember i was on the magic couch
yeah but there was also the chair with
the lever to put the legs up that was
brown
like the one over there there's like a
velvet one yeah that one's electric
because you're old now and you have a
button
but this one was a lever what about like
a love seat or a lounge
lounge chair you were in that damn
lounge chair forever
you had a bucket next to you for puking
and uh
you were very sick yep i'd cough up a
lot of [ __ ]
well what were you thinking about i mean
like at that point in time you had to be
going
[ __ ] i need to get better quick is that
really what you thought yeah
you didn't have any big life perspective
nope for being a big thinker you're not
really a deep thinker dad
um i don't deep think i whatever comes
to my mind i
i think about i don't yeah that's also
not that's not deep that's
i'm not deep you don't contemplate if
you don't contemplate the fabric of a
reality
you mean that's not something that you
do no
no i i i know yeah you get a little out
there
only more and more all the time yeah you
do i mean
you know it's just
the simple if there's an answer to it
you just you think about it and you do
it and
move on to the next thing i don't have
to contemplate or
if i'm going to go buy something i don't
research for two weeks to find out
which one's cheaper where it's at or
which one's better i just go buy it
i am a little like that too i call it
diminishing returns on my investment of
time
there's a certain preliminary amount of
something that you can do to prepare
but the rest of it is like diminishing
returns on my investment of time
usually i like to buy what's usually the
best because i only want to buy it once
i remember my dad told me that oh really
yeah he says just
rather than buying the cheapest thing
out there you end up buying it twice it
costs you more money just by the best of
one time huh what was your dad like i
actually didn't know him
um he died um so uh he died when i
when brooke was born right now when you
were born me okay um so
he died in 83. okay so i was one ish
my dad was your typical uh 50s um
fongias type with a hair comb back with
the comb in his pocket and
did he legitimately have a comb in his
pocket all the time and he used the
brill cream and all that oh yeah it was
back there yeah okay
all right well that's just that's a
description i got we've got a visual now
what was he like
i think my dad was very intelligent i
think he was smart but
um unfortunately alcohol got the best of
them
yeah and he drank too much and cut his
life short
yeah do you think that's why you don't
drink as much
i think it's part of it um
the other part is i just don't have time
or the
i don't mind a beer here or there but i
just don't go out to get loaded
you know yeah just not never done that
yeah well you told me a story you know
way back in the day of
you know you didn't want him to come to
your race as drunk and he would
yeah right he always had a flask you
know
he had it in his morning coffee puts
them in it every day
that's how bad it got so what the racism
is your mom say
what was she gonna say i don't know i
mean was that like the era where mom
doesn't
can't say anything no she cares
because i remember grandma drinking
bloody mary's all the time too the same
thing yeah it was just she was there too
kind of an era yeah so they they were
cut from the same you know they were
similar yeah
they were the like frequencies of each
other oh yeah back in the 50 they all
smoked i mean they were smoking two
three packs a day
which is not the norm anymore but that's
what it was back then
well i mean your dad died of lung cancer
when he was 44 44 and your mom
died of partial complications from that
copd and all kinds of things she had a
lot wrong with her when she was 61
right yep like it blows my mind i know
i'm kind of bouncing all over the place
but it blows my mind to
to think about like if
you know you losing your dad when he was
44 and you were 16
or how old were you yeah um
he died in 82 so i'd have been 23 oh
yeah i was thinking about both you and
mom
a lot lost your dads when you were
teenagers but you were a little i was
one
so um man
that'd be crazy was that was it hard or
was it not i mean like
did you resent him so much that it
didn't it didn't resent him um
did i miss him time to time yeah i mean
when he was sober he was a great guy
well what was he like then tell me about
like the best version
let's see he he was very intelligent he
he thought a lot like you know i think
like he does i should say
not like well that's kind of why i'm
asking is because look i'm like you
i know that and i'm trying to figure out
how you got to be you because that's how
i got to be like i
am yeah my dad was very creative i think
i wouldn't call him artsy but he was
very creative thinking he
he thought big too um well he obviously
started
patrick glass well my grandpa did that
my grandpa did that and he bought it for
my grandpa
okay well there you go the lineage of
big thinkers and starting businesses was
a long time ago
and then uh you know he just you know a
beer at lunch turned into beer all
afternoon and then was
you know stop we're getting to the best
version of dad
yeah best version best version
um i think he was
a lot of it was he's proud of me because
when we did race you know we always did
good
so he could walk around with his chest
out and stuff like like i did
you know so he was always proud of me he
was always proud of randy so
well that's because something you did
yeah but he opened the door for you took
us racing
right i'm wondering personality-wise i
mean him being boastful because you did
well is not
a great personality trait him like
taking you and like you know doing
something
fun with you on your own and hi guys
he's proud
ice fishing when we were younger and
stuff like that he'd take me with the
guys and stuff but you know
we go over to bagley wisconsin ice
fishing or you know
six eight guys in the car yeah i was the
beer opener
there's a lot of beer in these stories a
lot of beer
drinking and beer what kind of beer did
you drink my dad drank
well he drank hams or red or or paps
either one
bb army baby asap
apparently that was really you know well
they call like
tv or advertisements like they call it
programming
because that's what it's doing to you
right like you
the tv's telling you you need this oh my
god i need that or you know
the advertisement you see oh pb army
baby asap like oh i
i need a beer as soon as possible like
that programming was highly effective
it still works
pvr is like a funny thing at the bars
that happens now they're like oh man
it's pbr night like two dollar pbrs
is that what they sell it for anymore
like then they even come up with one was
red white and blue which was cheaper
oh wow wow but that'll that'll give me a
headache
so you look back at your dad and think
like that you're grateful for him or do
you look back and think
maybe maybe more than anything that he
taught you a lot through his
faults or you know when i look back
when i think of my dad i think of the
kansas song he had the world in his
hands
and he messed it up and he was a smart
man he had a business
but he chose to do alcohol
more than he chose to work and i'm going
to guess that you never found out why he
did that
no do she knew because it's all
neurological right it's
it comes down to a coping mechanism
again i i'm not that deep a thinker i
didn't ask you you know i didn't ask him
i didn't say dad why are you doing this
yeah you know they just do it yeah well
the problem with those kinds of
scenarios is then it becomes
like then the projection happens onto
well they're doing it because they don't
want to be with me
right that's kind of maybe some of the
feeling on the other side of it is like
i'm not enough
like i'm not enough to show up sober to
my right i think i think you're thinking
too deep about it
stop clipping my wings i mean
i think he liked his beer and he liked
hanging out the bars and he liked
drinking that's what they did in the 50s
60s
they didn't know any different that's
what they did
there's no explanation yeah but when
your son asks you to show up to a race
over and you can't
then that's a problem yeah he had a
problem
no he had he had a disease which was
alcoholism
from the brain and it could be the brain
says you need it because it's created
pathways that say like
this is what you do every day and he
reaffirmed it every single day it was
what he did
and then you unfortunately have the
physical side effects probably from
withdrawal which i don't know anything
about i've not i've just i'm guessing
that any kind of addiction
has some kind of uh penalty on the other
side like you know
if you feel sick the next day they call
it the hair you know have the hair of
the dog i don't know if that's just like
how it has to go
um if you stop then you feel bad i don't
really know but
um you know there are physical effects
of course too but
you know that would be interesting to
know because i bet that would
i don't know i would and it gets back to
one of those things you'll never know
i know you always tell me that you're
like don't try and figure things out
that you'll never know
i mean it just drives you nuts there's
so many things that i wonder about that
i'm never going to know until
you're never going no no no so it's like
i blow it off i'm not going to know
like do we live in a holographic
universe i don't know
but i don't until i die yeah exactly
does it matter i don't care
it doesn't matter i'm so curious though
oh my gosh do you think sometimes when i
talk like this you're like you're not my
daughter
well you're getting a little out there
sometimes but
[Laughter]
well you know it i think it's partly
being creative which is you tell me
something that
you are too you you're creative i mean
how about this for creativity
you buying brooke and mom and i matching
christmas outfits
every year every year and
then you find that i think how old was i
when that ended it was probably
you guys were probably 15 maybe yeah
because you decided that
bests were a good idea one year it was
like pants and a button-down
shirt and a vest and a hat and i was
like you told me i fell off the train
yeah i did you fell off the train dad
the fashion train
it looked cool now it was probably 30
years ago
you know like well it was easy i could
walk into one store
and like one outfit and get all three
all different sizes
because mom is so small yeah yeah mom
could fit in
what store was that you were limited to
limited too
oh yeah you had a what 30 day trial
there i did i worked at the limited 2
for
um maybe 30 for us for a winter so i
because i come back from england
i got in trouble for going out too much
and so you're like you're getting a job
and i'm like okay and i remember you
worked there because you wanted to
save enough money to go on spring break
yeah and you saved all like four hundred
dollars
yeah it is a good way to learn how money
goes really fast and you said what am i
gonna do i only got four hundred dollars
i said well
i keep working i guess i worked there
and so
um i was a bad employee um i
remember that there was there was two
scenarios that i got written up for
one of them was someone came in asking
for a certain lotion flavor or smell
and i said oh um let me come help you
help you find that and i look for it and
she goes well i asked you because i
thought you'd know
and then i could like nobody ever
remembers the first rude when they are
rude to me because mine is like
so inappropriate and i yeah your fuse is
pretty short it's
i don't have one i'm just it's like oh
[ __ ] did i just say that
whoops um so yeah i think i snapped back
at her and said like
well i've only worked here for two days
so yeah i have no idea where your lotion
is and i got written up for that and
then there was one other one where
someone came to the checkout for
they had that we we sold um these little
mini garbage cans
um were an odd size and uh
she wanted a box for it for christmas to
wrap it and i said to her
uh you know we don't have a box that
size and she said well if you sell it
you should have a box
and i said well ma'am given the fact
that it's the only thing that size in
the entire store
it makes sense why we don't have a box
and i got written up for that too
yeah you didn't last long not the
greatest of employees
i needed to start out my own businesses
yeah i needed to be my own boss
because you're fashionably late why are
you so i got that entrepreneurial kind
of
like mindset like you did so why do you
why do you why can't you work for
someone else
why can't i because i feel
first of all i'm gonna outwork them and
then you won't be rewarded
like they will because you're working
for them mm-hmm so if you're going to
put the work in you want the upside yep
there's nobody type casting people that
if they work for someone they're lazy
no no i know that's not true no
it's just you asking people are rewarded
you ask me purchases and raises and all
kinds of competitive and even work i
mean if somebody thinks they can work
more me i'm gonna work more
i'm gonna work harder yeah you know it
gets down to the competitiveness you
hate to lose at anything remember our
monopoly games
yeah family monopoly night never
finished did we did you cheat
i'm sure i could if i would see that's
the one thing about me though is i will
i don't want to win by cheating like
card games and all that stuff so what i
tell somebody is if they're like
they're like holding their cards you
know and they're like this and
they lean over or i can kind of see i'll
like quickly glance and look away and
i'll go
hi um i can see your cards and i'm
telling you because if you give me
another chance i am going to look at
them
well i'll do that give me the chance to
cheat i'll do that too but if i can
if i can i don't want to take some money
here or there
oh you keep wait wasn't that what your
uncle like gramps used to
put quarters underneath his beers yeah
so that when you guys played quarter uh
what was that game
um oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] and then when you
know you had to play with like three or
four quarters yeah you start with four
and then you lose four and you're out
you'll have two
magically underneath your beer yeah or
we'd play
cribbage and he would jump streets on me
if i was ahead i could never win in
cribbage until i jumped streets to win
that's just terrible cheating but you
love them let them do it paying
attention
paying attention but you got to do that
in business too
i mean any opportunity you can take
advantage of you do
yeah if somebody's going to let you you
take it don't you think
uh yeah i mean again i like i said i was
like i don't want to cheat but if you
keep putting it in my face i'm going to
do it because that's what's there yeah
no i
i i mean i'm i'm a hard worker when i'm
passionate about something
and i think that's something that i've
found as i've gotten older too is that
you know the things that aren't as
exciting to me or aren't
fun or aren't really like soul
fulfilling um
and passions um i i i get
i get bored and i don't want to do it i
don't want to do the work
yeah like but when you go to the gym you
want to outwork everybody there don't
sure or any of the other businesses that
i've started where i'm like
i'm into it i will work constantly
like i remember a couple of years ago i
was like launching the wine i was
writing the
book i was doing the website for for the
wet for the wine
and for um and for the book and i was
doing clothing line and i was doing all
these things
and i remember like once christmas hit
it was like probably december 21st or
2nd or something
and all of a sudden for the first time
in months i didn't have
something i could be doing that was work
like literally at all at all moments
you know whether it was editing chapters
selecting
photos um coming up with you know uh
color concepts or whether no matter what
it was or working out like i was
always keeping busy and so i had that in
me but i think that
well yeah well it's fun when you enjoy
it and i think that's the problem is
that a lot of people don't do things
that they enjoy
well that's you know that's our own
fault
right but
you know it's a means to an ends for
them and they don't believe that
they can make it a different way or
there's not enough not everybody can own
and run a business
right it's not in their personality it's
not in their personality it's not in
their work ethic it's not in their
brains it's not in their drive
there's a lot of things that it takes to
run a business and own a business
what does it take dad you started
well first of all you gotta know about
it you have to love it
you have to be willing to work and you
have to be willing to accept defeat
to make you better i mean not everything
goes perfect
yeah i mean to me that's part of the fun
of it is something goes wrong it's
trying to figure out how to fix it
what was your biggest failure in
business
good question
i don't know think deep dad
thinking deep i think the drywall
company i started that was with the
the the guy i gave him 50 to run
we had for a couple years and he had
more employees than i did and did
one third of the volume you know he just
kept hiring people to do the work
did you feel like but i but i did
somehow no
it was because i tried lead by example
and show him you need to work and get
better people and he was just one of
those
he was a foreman and i hired him from a
foreman job
to run it and he just got a divorce he
he just got divorced living in his
parents basement
so he had nothing else to do nothing
wrong with that i did live with you guys
but i'm late but i'm just saying he had
nothing else to do
so why wouldn't you work dive in dive in
and that was probably my biggest failure
i mean yeah it was money i didn't lose
money but i didn't make it
either like what did you what what
happened that made you go i ain't gonna
do that again
that i try i thought people would work
as hard as i would
and that's probably the the biggest
thing is finding somebody to work as
hard as i will and so that's why there's
never be a partner i won't have a
partner
i uh i feel like i've learned that on
some level as far as um
i have a saying for for some something
similar
that just because it's someone's job
don't expect them to do it well
yeah i think i went through my early
life thinking
i could do everything better than
everyone and then i went through a phase
of my life where i would just trust that
oh well
they're a professional let them do it
and then i had to come back around to
just because it's someone's job
doesn't mean they do it well people some
people
got to be pushed non-stop it's just how
it is i mean just
you're dealing with well with everybody
you understand so that's why you know
i'd never have another partner or i
won't have any more employees
yeah i just soon work seven and seven
days a week 12 hours a day anymore i
can't work 15 16 anymore i'm too old
i get too tired what's the um what's the
funnest thing
thing or things that you've been able to
do now that
you know um you're not working as much
i mean you kind of are i mean you'll
never not work you have a you have the
carbon fiber business
you you know you do you sort of are
always going to keep busy on some level
but what are some of the things that you
do now that are super fun
well every year me and mom take a big
vacation somewhere yeah i'm so proud of
you
guys and i told her i said you know mom
mom doesn't like to spend the money
i said no she's cheapskate she's cheap
so i said we're taking a vacation every
year
i don't care what it costs we're going
and we've been yeah
every year for the last seven or eight
years we've gone someplace big
yeah list them off where have you been
uh
let's see we did venice and down through
the adriatic sea through you know
dubrovnik and all those in croatia and
then we've done
the greek isles into uh turkey
uh ephesus we've seen ephesus that was
pretty cool
you know venice is cool we've done the
baltic sea
we've done um that was cold
in the summer and we did uh
um mediterranean where we did you know
ibiza and all those fun places and
we went to amsterdam and went damaged
been to amsterdam did you go to the
coffee shops
yeah we had no idea what we're doing
did you eat brownies yeah
it's so funny to talk to you about this
the the funny part was the funniest
story was
it's one of our best friends he's a army
ranger
and he's never drank or smoked ever
ever he's just straight laced so we're
in amsterdam and i had two brownies i
was eating one and he wanted to try one
so i gave him a little brownie he goes
these aren't bad
and i said you know they got potted and
he goes i don't feel anything and he ate
the whole brownie
how much are you supposed to eat just a
few bites
like a quarter of it he ate the whole
brownie so he was fried and he's never
been that way in his life
so we go to we we ended up going to this
uh we were in amsterdam went to a coffee
went to an actual coffee shop which is
starbucks and he tried ordering
tai chi latte he couldn't say that if he
had to none of us could
you're not saying it right either
exactly imagine saying it after eating a
full brownie
oh man that's funny that's really funny
wow did mom have one too she had a
couple nibbles
what's mom like hi she hasn't i don't
never seen her hide what she ate some
brownie
just you don't turn into a different
person
you don't no you don't start jumping
around jumping off
roofs and laying on the ground and doing
the worm and stuff like that you just
all right you just chill out all right
all right well that's that's good
i'm glad you guys relax and you you see
places and yeah
singapore thailand thailand for three
and singapore right yeah we ended up in
singapore
yeah you took the orient express you
said it sucked there's a reason there's
so many murders on the orient express
why because you're so bored you want to
kill somebody
okay that's not going to help with the
orient express um
tourism then that's mine that's that's
just shut it down
that's my opinion okay when somebody has
to tell me what to eat when to eat
on a vacation wow
and you're a really narrow eater like
you're a mean potatoes guy
and i'm so proud of you because in the
last year you started eating vegetables
yeah a little bit more this is a fact
like what you would only ever eat
raw cauliflower and broccoli and carrots
or raw broccoli
raw carrots cauliflower and celery yup
and now you put four leaves of spinach
in your smoothie in the morning
i'm wearing up to five leaves now and
i'm so proud of you because if i do any
more in that it turns it green and it
looks like [ __ ]
that's actually when i made a smoothie
and i was like man i just wanted to look
pretty so i didn't put any spinach
exactly when you put spinach in there it
turns brown
it looks like [ __ ] looks like [ __ ] it
looks like you're eating [ __ ] yeah and
we eat with our eyes
because absolutely so that's why it's
become things and i don't want to eat
[ __ ]
yeah maybe i need to put it in fun
better cups that are camouflaged why
don't they make spinach that's red
um i'm sure they could think about that
when you're deep thinking
they might i mean maybe they can put
like uh certain minerals into the dirt
and maybe it would do something
different i got you thinking now don't i
yeah
i'm gonna do that i'm gonna do like
smoothie friendly
colored spinach dangling carrot out
there for you
yeah that's a good idea i'ma start a
business there you go
such a brain such a business thinker
um so what did you think about me
retiring
i knew it was time why because you
weren't having any fun
it got to be more of a fight than it got
to be having fun
and i try and tell people that racing
isn't always fun it's a lot of work
and um it's
it's hard to find people and it's hard
to trust people and it's just a business
it's a it's a really hard business
that's the bottom line yeah don't you
think
well there's just a lot more failure
than success yeah you know uh the the
the success is presumably like
winning right but it's not that's not
going to happen
very often no like i described to people
in nascar like
the best of the best that's had a
phenomenal season out of 38 races will
win
five yeah you know um so you know
you know being five and uh
33 is that right five and thirty fifteen
percent yeah is is
is it not is that 150 is not a good
percentage right but that's how it is in
racing from winning and losing
perspective so you have to find
victories along the way that aren't
victories and like they go to victory
lane
so essentially there's a lot more
failure than there is success
and i think that's hard to digest now
you know
tony canada and i were joking about how
we can blame the car and that that maybe
is the best thing about racing is that
you have something to blame
um as opposed to so many other sports
like stick and ball kind of sports where
they're like yeah i just you know
just can't uh just can't uh throw the
ball that far
um i guess that's just my arm so
you know you have things to blame but on
the other hand if you're very talented
there are things that could be the
problem that aren't you
and that and most of the time and
probably is the car
i mean i i like i tell people all the
drivers out there either nascar indy car
you get them the exact same car they
they're all within a tenth or two
talent-wise yeah there's no reason that
somebody's two seconds off the car isn't
as good you can only
everybody that's in the hall of fame of
any racing has been with the best team
yeah of course yeah and that's one of
those things the best best
also attracts the best right so then the
best teams get the best
drivers drivers you know
engineers there may be better drivers
that never made it as far and yeah you
know so yeah
yeah right place right time it is an
interesting sport like that
and then sponsors you know play another
element too
um it is an interesting and sponsors are
yeah i mean
in racing sponsorship's getting harder
yeah nobody has the same card two weeks
in a row
sometimes you do not really often yeah
anymore yeah
um so you knew it was time for me to be
done yep
and what did you think i was gonna do
i i i think you've done about what i
thought you'd probably take a year off
and travel and do nothing
i thought you'd do that i didn't do
nothing dad
but yeah i didn't do as much no
so i mean you you didn't you didn't go
forward with a few businesses yeah you
just
you went you got more involved in the
winery but the clothing line you you
know you
kind of set that in the back burner for
a little bit and you're back on it and
so i mean i knew you'd take a year off
and just regroup and
i knew that would drive you nuts and
you're going probably right now you're
chomping on a bit to go i gotta start
doing something
well i get bored you know and i think
that that was always something i felt
like was healthy about racing too was
you know i loved the off season because
i wanted to get to the point where i was
actually bored and ready to get back at
it
um so i think that that balance is
important
um and uh and i and i
yeah so i'm you know i'm ready to get
back at it i've been on
eight vacations in four months and i'm
or three months and i'm not complaining
but
it it definitely meant that i was
traveling a lot so yeah
i knew that and and there'll be a point
where you wake up more going i gotta do
something
yeah i do wake up and have those moments
right
okay i think i had one of those moments
last year
um after sort of being away from you
know being done for a few months and
like aaron had just signed his big
contract and
i was kind of just like hanging out you
know and
i remember just thinking to myself i
have to
[ __ ] do something with my life and
i'm not the kind of person that doesn't
like i mean i have the winery i have the
book i have the
you know i have other things that are
going on like i have things that can
keep me busy but i remember thinking to
myself and again
contrast and perspective is such an
interesting thing but i remember
thinking
i'm like oh my god i need i need to
accomplish something in my life
and you know people might laugh at that
kind of comment based on what i've done
in my career but that's how i feel i'm
like
you know just motivated person to to do
great things
and you you need to do it 100 too that's
the key
i think that's where people they they
dabble a little bit they do a little bit
and they expect something to come of it
and that doesn't come yeah
you have you have to jump in with both
feet and anything you do
well yeah but i think that you know you
do have to sort of
feel into what what's working for you
and what's not and if you keep hitting
roadblocks with things like maybe you
didn't need to have the drywall business
because
you know the glass business need more
attention or something
i don't know but you know you have to
look at those roadblocks as being
you know like traffic signs right like
go this way not that way
um i think that's how i look at those
well you determine those when you get to
it
but you have to know you've done
everything you can like you have to know
you've tried really hard and go
you know what i'm done hitting my head
against the wall um
i'm gonna just say that this is not for
me but it's just like everything in life
everything changes
you know you just gotta be able to adapt
i mean
back when i was growing up kmart was big
now there's no more kmart you know
all these companies get big and then
somebody else gets bigger and who
thought walmart would be
taking over is smaller than than uh
amazon um yeah well at one point yeah i
mean
that happens in business all the time
just when you get complacent and you
think
all right it's going good somebody's
gonna come in and beat your ass yeah
so you gotta stay on it you have to
adapt and and change i mean
yeah you know same with your winery
you'll find out you're going to start
doing some other things you'll probably
buy another winery who knows
i mean there are things going on behind
the scenes that are that people don't
know about yet but you know
it's um one of them does pertain to wine
but yeah so i mean you can't be
complacent
you know yeah you can't just put in your
your time and expect it to go
yeah in anything yeah even in in racing
and
in life that's why i teach people when i
was doing go-karts for kids i said this
is a good life lesson
racing go-karts because you get out what
you put into it you got to work hard
you can't just it's not always going to
go well no you can't just throw money
and expect it to happen
yeah has to be heart desire and talent
was it hard i know i'm kind of like i
feel like i'm flipping the
flipping the script to the beginning but
was it hard to figure out how to raise
brook and i
like how to like what to teach us or
what to what to put emphasis on
or you know like was it difficult
because i think about parenting and i
think
you know how do you how how can you be
disciplined enough with your kids that
they don't get in trouble and get hurt
or have something bad happen
it's pretty easy um but but you know not
be so
wrangled that they you know rebel
every every parent's different you know
on their aspects of what they look at
i i thought it was easy because
basically you do
what you think is right and everybody
thinks what is right is different
you know how many times i tell you you
can't go out drinking
because you were hard on me yeah because
i knew in the long run
what was what was your first big sponsor
what they do they went back and checked
your record
and would they find dad you just had
speeding tickets that's right up high
because speeding tickets qualify me for
a job in a race car yeah but if you got
caught for something else
you know you know million dollar
sponsors go away i mean yeah
yeah you have to you have to present
yourself what you want to get to well
and you lie
too because that's what i tell parents
too that they're like how do i you know
they talk about their own kids and i
said
you know just put the fear of god in
them because that's what my dad did to
me he told me if you get caught drinking
and driving you'll never race again if
you don't have a license
if you do drugs and you get drug tested
you will never be able to race again
true though and you want to know what i
never got drug tested until i started
racing indy cars
and um when i i mean as far as drinking
goes
you know yeah you don't want to drink
and drive that's a good that's a good
goal
it's a good good good motto or do drugs
or do drugs i mean drugs lead to bad
things too
um when not done in moderation or you
know with the right mindset so
um yes anyway i i those are those are
good things but you did lie
on some level but no i know because i
was like 15
and you told me like don't do these
things they were never going to be part
of my
you can race without a driver's license
dad can you get a fia card
i think so you can i know you can race
without a license people have had
licenses revoked and be able to race i
might call [ __ ] carpet
and i didn't get drug tested for a long
long long time
are you saying you missed out on
something
um you know what i'm there's time for
everything and so
i'm not gonna say that uh you know kind
of like you with having kids really
young i'm not gonna say that um
it's being a parent it's that's that's a
bold statement
i think it's very easy to treat them
with respect and you treat them how you
were brought up and how
you were raised you're gonna do the same
thing well then maybe i mean
here's the thing though that's why i
kept asking you about your parents and
about your dad is because you know
obviously i'm a lot like you and
you're a lot like your parents and your
parents were like so how did that happen
and i'm just wondering where it came
from and
it's just interesting i mean that's the
nature of nurture yeah but you can't say
that because you know there's
every no two kids are the same just like
you and brooke aren't the same
you know you're pretty close but me and
my brother aren't the same
yeah you know we're polar opposites
alum loving to death but we're just
polar opposites yeah hey
yeah you're different for sure so i mean
i'm sure if ea has no regrets in life
i'm sure he does so
if i ever had kids what would be your uh
what would be your advice for me
um i'll tell you the same thing i told
brooke
brooke struggled her first three or four
months with the kids
she didn't know what to do and i told
her i said
until you realize your life is no longer
yours that it's your kids
you'll struggle with it you pretty much
do everything for your kids
once you have them do you think that's
healthy yeah and you think that's
you think that otherwise otherwise
otherwise there's um
resentment against them i mean
because they're not allowing you to go
do something because you got to do
something with them or
so you're saying you need to accept that
you have to accept that and be happy to
accept that i'm being happy
to accept that or don't have kids right
you know you know
you have to be all in with them you're
just an online kind of guy dad
yeah i get it i'm just like that yeah i
mean
otherwise i mean why do it you can't go
swimming one arm can you
no dad you wouldn't go very far no you
wouldn't
that's half-assed he'd sink i think you
got your whole ass
just one arm
all right well thank you for chatting
with me dad yeah
thank you for um we didn't even talk
about racing did we
well that's because i usually don't i
know you don't like talk about racing
that's what everybody says what's dan
get thinking
i don't know she doesn't talk about
racing
i never have no i mean there's like a
download after a race for an hour or two
sometimes like after but then that's it
but i think that that explains why i'm
you know 37 and retired and doing other
things because
i while i loved racing yeah i mean
of course i wouldn't do something for 27
years if i didn't love it and you were
all in
but i yeah of course all in for sure
going to england and not going to prom
and doing all
they were never a problem i was happy to
do them they were part of the program
they were part of the process
but that was how i just had a goal and
once i felt like the fun part and the
goal was not realistic anymore
then i was like well i'm done and i'm
not attached to the
identity where you can't find an answer
you don't keep pursuing it
yeah yeah so stop thinking deep danica
stop is that your you're so deep you can
still think deep
but you gotta you gotta choose what
things to go after and trying to
understand well i think what you know
what i'm learning is that
you you actually live in the present
just a little bit better maybe than a
lot of people
you're not putting i mean now look
you've had your moments you're very
um yes you're passionate as we've um and
you get angry and
you know there are some some unhealthy
sort of
personality traits and attachments that
create a negative behavior
but but in general like
i think you just kind of live in the
present pretty well
like i try and explain to people
everybody tries to figure out what
they're gonna how they're gonna fix the
problem before they get into it
yeah then when you get in the problem
it's different you're screwed yeah oh
and then you're thinking about the
problem too
so you wait till you get the problem
then you fix it because it's kind of
self-explanatory once you get into it
right and you're wasting time and your
weight never happens if yeah
so if it happens different it happens
different you know i can do this if it
does this well if it doesn't do that
i don't know you gotta fix it anyway
so deal with the present you can waste a
lot of time trying to figure your [ __ ]
out beforehand
i like it deal with the present i don't
i did that in business there but no
didn't know how i was going to do
something i figured it out once you get
into it you figure it out
do you think that that's just because
you believed that you would figure it
out yeah absolutely
right so in your heart you knew it
you're like i will figure
anything out pretty much everything gets
figured out don't so do you think that
people try and fix the problem before
they happen out of fear
and then that they that they don't
really believe it's going to go well
probably so believe in yourself
and deal with the present and deal with
the present pretty simple
it's like golf head down swing easy i
struggle with both
simple deep thoughts simple deed
thoughts by danger
simple impactful thoughts not me i'm not
saying them no i'm over here talking
about quantum physics i'm way deep
thinking over here i'm overthinking i'm
overthinking dad
yeah you know you're way overthinking
you get out there
i get i should be able to tell the story
about the your bowls over there that
sing
oh yeah go ahead and make fun of me if
you want go for it it's okay it was last
year
you were here and you had your bowls and
you were you were going through a
podcast you said look at that the moon
is fake
you see you see that see that blip in
there in that video
it's spliced together i won't really
i do questions okay so
let me finish the story so then the next
night
you come out of the bedroom carrying
your you're singing bowls over there and
you're putting them outside and going
what the hell are you doing
he said well it's a it's a super moon
it's a super moon it was a big superman
super moon i gotta recharge my bowls i
looked over and said i thought the moon
was fake
i think you said f you dad
that's what dads are for check and
recheck keeping it real keeping it real
keeping it real what do you i mean what
do you think i'm going to do now
that i'm you know not racing anymore and
taking some time to get bored
like what do you where do you see what
do you see me doing in
like ten years i you know this podcast
thing it kind of when you were doing it
i'm thinking
it's kind of good for her because she
asked a lot of stupid questions
like stuff like we were talking about
there's no answer to that there's no
proof of it
okay i mean there's people who go on
there and just start talking about just
so they can be relevant
that's what i think so you think i'm
just trying to be relevant
no i'm not the but i'm thinking this
will work for a while then you're going
to go
i need to get my business going you'll
get a good clothing line going the way
you want
and i think the winery will i think
you'll end up with another winery
because one isn't enough to make money
so you make two of them you make money
and when you're not making money at one
double down get another
no it's a volume well yeah it's a low
volume high price point yeah
so you know what i'm saying yeah and
then i see the clothing line
picking up and what about what i do
every day
food and fitness i've been waiting for
you to tell me you're going to do a
food network show with healthy food
i think that would be big because nobody
eats healthy yeah
i mean you've preached it in my head and
even not when i go out to eat i look at
people and going
they can't eat that it's going to kill
them good job
i know but it's like eat for life yes
like eat to live eat i think you're
either adding to your
well-being or you're reducing it it's
one or the other with food i think
that's that's one of your bigger
messages and to get with kids because it
all starts with kids
yeah kids kids need to eat right to
begin with i never did
yeah so you never have that habit yeah
if you had a
kids food network or something yeah when
kids come home from school
yeah well the the platforms are changing
you know it's not
all tv there's digital platforms there's
there's all kinds of different but you
see you get your message out there that
way with your food because you're very
smart
and very passionate about it and it is
right i mean people don't
so i mean it's a good message yeah i
think it's a better message
than micro adams or whatever the hell
else you're talking about
my opinion micro
atoms or whatever with my daughter
danica pantry
so i see that yeah and um
then you know do some cooking shows and
you film those
you know three weeks about my workout
stuff there's so many workout things
i think they're all out there i i think
that's too watered down i think your
niche
will be your food yeah and and i've said
it before even with
something with kids because there's if
you look at anything that
the parents do they'll spend any amount
of money on their kids
yeah no matter what yeah so if a kid
asks for broccoli they're going well
we're eating [ __ ] broccoli tonight
exactly
you know so it's like i think that's a
better message than
because you're about the message more
than you are the anything
well yeah i mean you know you're very
influential
because of you know you've been
successful and i'm very passionate about
these things
and you get passionate about it that's
why that's where i see you going from
here
yeah is that area yeah yeah
you know the cookbook i am cookbooks are
fine i think they're great but i would
like i told you i would rather see it on
a video so something put it on their
phone
oh my gosh remember a few years ago you
bought me a gopro and all kinds of
apparatuses
to film my cooking you go here you go
this is for you to fill your cooking
while you're doing it
it had a headband with a gopro you put
on it so you know how much you put in
it's right you turn your phone on you
set it right there and you go
okay a little bit of this a little bit
of that stop get it
it's easier than reading it yeah you're
definitely a movie guy not a book guy i
know that every
but but everybody most people are visual
than they are reading yeah the visual
does help yes
you you're always a leading i mean
you're always on the leading edge of
of tech stuff you're you're looking
you're checking it out you've got your
finger on the pulse
that was years ago and obviously you
know food that was three or four years
ago
that was at least that yeah and i i
didn't do it i stayed in the box and i'm
sorry about that but it did
no big deal yeah you have bought many
many
tech items over the years that are um
very pointless in my life but every now
and again there's one good one
i haven't known it yeah so do you use
that smooth for the
i try yes it's a little difficult you
can use it for the stand anyway
i do i use it for the stand there you go
to be able to it works for the standard
stuff
yeah it does carry it does give it a
nice level balance
yep and i don't know if you'll have kids
or not i mean you think that's up to you
i think that's up in the air sure is
yeah that's your call
my body my temple um yeah
and someday i hope you do yeah well it's
one of those things i've spent my entire
life making sure that i don't
that it's a weird concept for me even um
but you know brooke's kids are so cool
and yeah you know
i i can see that being you know but i
see it being consuming right because
when
you're ready to do it you do you go all
in and then that that's what i worry
about i mean it's
you got to go all in with them and your
life is no longer yours but then there's
interesting things that can happen from
that too when you have that much passion
in a little person you start looking you
try i
would imagine being like entrepreneurial
like i am like you
um is that i'd probably find things that
i
feel like could be done better or made
better
or something that would help the process
be easier whether it be through
education through products themselves
maybe healthy baby food you know
whatever it is but i can see there being
like things like that that i'd go
there's nothing in the market for this
exactly i'm going to fix it you're going
to fix it exactly
so you think that way so yeah and you're
you're talking about the well-being of
you know most important thing in the
world so
yeah they do become like the most
important thing yeah i bet that was
i mean well i mean like we were your
like brooke and i were your life like
did you feel like when
when we went when we were gone that and
i think that happens to a lot of parents
right their identity gets wrapped up in
their kids at times
and you know was that something that you
were like
well now what do we do like abev
you know what she wants you know me and
mom go through this all the time it's
like
have you talked dank you know have you
no
and she gets kind of down because she
likes to just talk to you
once a week whatever phone call pick up
the phone
and i i look over and say she's 37 years
old do you talk to your mom every week
do you call your mom no maybe you should
so i mean it's you know deal with the
present
deal with the present look at you i mean
it's you know
you'll go through it too i mean you know
it's it's all about feelings right so
i'm making her
i'm obviously making her feel like she's
not important but then when you flip the
script and you go hey
but are you calling your mom and she
says no it's like oh [ __ ]
i better check myself right like why am
i offended
why am i mad at her when i'm really just
like you know when i'm doing the same
thing and it's just comes down to
feeling offended and and that's i mean i
do it too like i get offended easily and
i'm trying to get better about it but
it's true i mean i get offended
and you know it's it's i probably one of
the
biggest things in in
and and with humans is that we get
offended easily
because whether it's coming from someone
else that's nothing of ours to deal with
that's projection or whether it's our
own insecurities and someone triggers us
but
but i think it's i think that's just the
way kids are now i've talked to many
parents and
eleven out of ten parents will call
their kids and they don't answer
if you send them you didn't say eleven
out of ten i did say eleven out of ten
i know your numbers guy i know eleven
out of ten
and i'm not so i'm like and when they
call they won't answer if you send them
a text they will
it takes so little time just pick the
phone and say hey mom hey dad how you
doing
yeah i think that you're right it comes
because i i feel like you want to talk
for it like i feel like if i pick up the
phone i'm like i need
spare time and a text is like you can do
other things while you're doing it it's
a multi-tasking sort of platform but you
have your phone on you
yeah so if if you're going you pick up
hey mom and dad
and even one minute say how are you
doing
i'll call you on the way to the gym in
green bay it only takes
nine minutes and you call me you you
call me seven minutes into it so you
only have two minutes
okay i just put hi dad what are you
doing all right i just pulled up i gotta
go well now you know for accountability
purposes if i don't call you right away
we have less than eight minutes exactly
i'll ask you where you're at when you
call
mm-hmm if i'm on the highway and i'm
you're like that and i'm like that
brooks like that brookson's work gets in
the car she calls somebody
that's you you and her are like cut from
the same cloth get in the car
talk on the phone i get in the car and
i'm like you know how much i listen to
the radio
every day all day now i don't want to
listen the radio anymore
i know every song podcast so much more
interesting yeah but some
it seems like all the podcasts i listen
to are really the ones you send me are
just too deep i'm too shallow
okay i'll walk out to knee deep then
you'll screw straight down
all right we'll keep it simple dad keep
it simple live in the now
live in the now keep it simple all right
life becomes easier
you won't lay awake at night going of
course i do think about
crazy [ __ ] like aliens are out there
there are definitely aliens out there
yeah
for anyone to think that we're the only
people in the universe i mean really no
some of the [ __ ] that's out there built
aliens like there was a great
pyramid come on right you used to say
that when i was a kid you were like
pyramids aliens built them and i
remember you saying that
now that i'm older and i'm like curious
about that stuff and like
yeah i mean i just listened to a great
podcast that joe rogan did with graham
hancock and
um you know it was about you know a lost
civilization from sort of
11 and a half to 12 and a half thousand
years ago and how
you know you know maybe there was
information from
you know maybe back then they had more
advanced technology than we even have
now
um and yeah look at that and going when
the helmet
was cataclysm a billion years going on
nobody was there
there's no newspaper there we're
speculating
can't prove it necessarily although they
are finding artifacts that are
significantly older than um than we
thought uh human existence was
so yeah yeah well aliens
aliens they live at a different
frequency we
we can only see them when they come that
could be i'm not throwing that out there
but it's like
they're out there they're out there
they're out there yeah well
you should do a podcast in in uh area 52
51 51 yeah yeah i think that i've heard
that that's one of those places where
you drive out there and you're like
there's checkpoints before you even get
close to where you're going and when you
leave
very radioactive glows you glow dad
we all glow when we're happy yeah
um so um the other question um
so you know you and mom agreeing
to actually this is a funny story so
from zero to ten years old this was an
agreement that you and mom made from
zero to ten years old
mom would be the final decision maker
for us as kids yep and then from 10 to
20
that was gonna be you dad that's correct
okay so is that
why i got to go to england when i was 16
probably i don't know if mom would let
you
really i don't know i mean you probably
had to check with mom about
your daughter not going to high school
anymore and dropping out and you know
moving to it and you know i get i get
that same question how could you do that
and
i it's easy to just go how could i not
the opportunity was there and that's
what she wanted to do
how's your college yeah there's nothing
left here for you
you need i mean it was the right thing
to do what i had done different yes but
it was the right thing to do
yeah i think what was it like when i was
gone mom cried a lot right
oh yeah we all did it was tough yeah
you know it was hard like what would
make you cry just
just sitting there wondering what you're
doing and
you know if something's not going right
or going bad and you know you can't be
there
yeah when you can't be there for your
kid that's when it hurts most
because when they need you and you can't
be there that's hard
what was i like before i left and what
was i like when i came back
you were the happy-go-lucky kid when you
come back you were just kind of
jaded hard
cold thank you you described me like
being kind of cold
don't let it won't let anybody in yeah
even if somebody loved you
just when you just kind of blew them off
you know turn the emotion switch off
well it was bad it was horrible it was
horrible i know i know it was
i hated it i mean it was like every year
was worse and
you know it's cool and a novelty when
you're 16 to leave high school and be
like see
you know you guys were crying as i'm
like like smiling and waving and running
as fast as i could to the airplane
um you know i was i was i was fine with
it because it was an exciting new
adventure for me but
um you know it that wore off the novelty
wore
off and you know you realize that you're
alone and
people are dicks and you know they don't
they're not very nice to you
and english don't like americans let
alone american girl in racing it's just
it was a bad scenario yeah but i don't
think you'd have been the person you
were
if you didn't do it do you of course not
no everything
everything is part of the process it's
part of the part of the growth
so you know one of those lessons that i
learned over there was not to trust
everyone
i tell kids that now they i said you
need to go over an england race
or in european race because the racing
over here is too easy
well i mean i i mean look at i mean you
were racing against the best of the best
yeah i mean i
there was a lot of people from my era
that continued on um in different
forms of racing yeah like a lot of them
pretty much like
everybody you grew up racing go-karts
and they all they all
made a job of it so um but yeah i mean
it's
i think that was a lot of it is did you
ever think about bringing me home
or like saying like that's it or was it
just like when
we ran out of money we did yeah you know
there was
we were didn't have anything left so i
think we were
looking at each other going we had 30
000 left in our bank account
and it's like that's about another month
over there we can't do it anymore
because brooke had to go to college that
was coming up yeah you know
so it was time well
you didn't i mean that was
that was not necessarily you just
telling me to come home but it was kind
of a
cumulative decision it was it was what
we had to do
you know we couldn't do it anymore
you know and at that point there was 1.7
ratio so
oh yeah the money exchange with money
exchange so it was very expensive
yeah you know ain't so much the racing
it was living expense everything
yeah well phone bills you know all that
little stuff living
because you were living on your sorry i
wouldn't have bought so many clothes and
cds over there if i would have
just quit losing your cds you lost them
all one time i did i
was like i gotta get my britney spears
and my christina aguilera back yeah
so you replaced all my cds yep
well we knew you had to be happy so we
did whatever it did to make you happy
that's a decision that's an interesting
topic about making your children happy
like brooke and i could have very easily
just been or become like the statistical
spoiled
kids where we didn't really do much we
just
got by i'll disagree really
because if you wouldn't have been good
kids you wouldn't get spoiled
i can promise you that okay well that's
good because we were super spoiled so
that means we were super good
you were super good you didn't do drugs
you didn't get in trouble
yeah you know yeah so and we got good
grades
i mean i mean you respected us and you
didn't talk back and
if it was different it wouldn't happen i
can promise that
i just thought you guys were totally
soft
do you really think so yeah somewhat
here and there i mean you know the the
the and you know parents go to the ends
of the earth for their children
um and sometimes they're dicks and they
don't deserve it how about the first
time you were drinking what happened
oh god was i soft yeah no i got in big
trouble i got grounded for a month
and what did you have to go do i think i
had to test my go-kart
in the sleep sleeting icing rain my
hands were numb
all day all day yeah that's right
that's right you you probably didn't
know what a hangover was you're in the
go-kart
all day just us out there that was the
only ones out filled her up
mm-hmm change gloves here's some dry
ones yeah that's right
was that soft yeah that's right all
right dad fair play
so credit where credit's due
as child and i was a decent child you
were a good kid okay
let's stop there sounds good
all right all right love you love you
dad thanks
[Music]
you